as Ford and other companies report steep
losses economists expect the biggest
economic contraction in many years
unions call for measures to protect
workers after President Trump moved to
keep meat processing plants open many US
labs said they could process far more
Kobe 19 diagnostic tests than doctors
and hospitals have ordered
I'm Shelby Holliday and here's what you
need to know today as the Commerce
Department releases its initial estimate
of first quarter GDP economists expect
an even steeper economic decline in the
first half of 2020 companies have been
hit hard by the pandemic Ford posted a
nearly two billion dollar loss Southwest
Airlines recorded its first quarterly
loss in nine years and Starbucks saw its
first same-store sales drop in more than
a decade even for businesses with virus
related products and services the
picture is mixed at best 3m and UPS have
benefited from people loading up on
supplies but they lost out on profitable
chunks of their businesses such as big
deliveries to offices and stores there's
plenty of supply its distribution and we
will probably have that today amid
worries that closures of food processing
plants could disrupt u.s. meat supplies
President Trump
invoked the defense production act to
keep them running unions have criticized
the action and called for stronger
worker testing and safety measures
plants operated by Tyson Smithfield and
others have closed down as they recorded
hundreds of cases among employees and
other workers chose to stay home an
official said the Labor Department is
crafting guidance to protect workers
many commercial and academic labs in the
u.s. say they're processing coronavirus
tests far below their daily capacity
roughly one-and-a-half million kovat 19
diagnostic tests were processed in the
u.s. within the past week but the number
could scale to 3 million within eight
weeks according to some experts public
health officials say much more testing
is needed labs blame barriers including
fragmented supply chains and a lack of
centralized data on where capacity
exists
last week the administration provided
governor's with lists of sites with
unused testing capacity